Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen Tim.
Mehrere.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik, hundertsiebenundachtzig, äh, direkt aus dem Sommerloch. Ist schon ein Sommerloch, nee, noch nicht ganz, ne? Aber äh es deutet sich an. Ne, Sommerloch ist nicht die richtige Bezeichnung. Wie nennt man denn so eine Phase der Ablenkung?
Äh es ist wieder Burring-Wetter. Burrying heißt es, begraben. Man man vergräbt doch die News
man man vergräbt das das eigentliche Geschehen hinter der EM, ne? Während so ein prittlafter in seinem selbst im Politikpodcast die ganze Zeit nur noch vor Tor und und Abseits redet, dann gehst du hin und dann machst du mal so eben so Antiterror-Paket, schön gemütlich, guckt grad keiner, kann man in Ruhe mal einmal,
durchregieren, ne? Es ist wieder.
Grabes Wetter. Klingt doof. Begripptenswetter.
Stimmung. Begrenzstimmung ist auf jeden Fall.
Für diejenigen, die äh hingucken.
Der englische Nationalmannschaft macht. Sorry.
Da ist sie jetzt.
Wir haben es alle sehr genossen.
Ich ich äh ich habe das äh nur am Rande mitbekommen. Man kann sich ja in Berlin gerade nicht bewegen, ohne die Fußballergebnisse mitzubekommen. Ah ich war schon echt erstaunt, wie ähm.
Wie der der zweite Brexit in der vergangenen Woche dann doch sehr gefeiert wurde von den von den europäischen und nicht europäischen Fußball äh Fans, die alle sich dat angeguckt haben und gesagt haben das ist doch schön.
Ja, das tun wir mal. Gerechtigkeit sieg.
So fühlt sich ein Brexit an.
Ja gefühlte Gerechtigkeit, ne? Aber währenddessen äh im Hintergrund andere Dinge.
Ja während wir alle uns freuten, dass äh wer war das Island, ne? Das Island ähm,
Vollzug. Vollzogen hat. Ähm,
wurde im Bundestag dann das Antiterror-Paket beschlossen, das Anti-Terror-Paket ist das Gesetz zur Umsetzung der Maßnahmen zur Terrorismusbekämpfung,
Und ähm es ist ein Gesetz wie wie das so äh wie ich das schon so öfter beschrieben habe, dass heute Gesetze so ein bisschen in als DIV publiziert werden,
Wo also verschiedene Gesetze auf einmal geändert werden. Und wir haben ähm.
Also es ist eigentlich gar nicht so sehr ein Gesetz, sondern es ist mehr so eine Änderungsmaßnahme, genauso Änderungsmaßnahme, die sich dann auf mehrere existierende Gesetze auswirkt.
Genau und da wird dann äh nach Absatz so und so wird folgender Satz geändert, so so lauten für bei mehreren Gesetzen so. Aber bei den meisten glaube ich sogar,
Ähm und jetzt haben wir die endgültige Abschaffung der anonymen Mobilfunkkommunikation durch diese verschärften Regeln zu namentlichen Registrierung, wenn in der Prepaid-Karte holst. Ähm das war natürlich immer schon so,
dass äh dass du du konntest in Deutschland nichts keine SIM-Karte bekommen, die vollständig anonym war, aber es war.
Schon, aber nicht in Betrieb nehmen.
Ja, also genau du konntest keinen keinen Account,
bei einem Mobilfunkprovider haben, wo nicht irgendwo eine Identität zu gelingt ist und,
aber das wurde halt nicht nicht besonders überprüft und so konntest du halt dann irgendwie in
in Berlin, was weiß ich, im Speti, diese Karten kaufen und im Rahmen der Kundenzufriedensheizmaßnahmen waren die halt alle aktiviert auf irgendjemanden und gut ist. Ähm was hier jetzt passieren soll, ist, dass die,
dass das überprüft werden muss
Da kommt übrigens auch auf die Mobilfunkprovider jetzt natürlich eine riesen Arbeit vor äh zu, ne? Die haben äh weiß ich nicht jetzt gut, jetzt gemütliche zwanzig Jahre Prepaid-Karten ausgehändigt und sind jetzt verpflichtet, das alles zu prüfen
Die sind da ähm mittelbegeistert von von diesem Gedanken.
Nachvollziehbar.
Dann haben wir die sogenannte ähm,
Entgrenzung internationaler Überwachungsdatenbanken,
Wie der Ingo äh sehr schön bei äh Netzpolitik Ork schreibt,
Bei dem ich das, bei dem lese ich hier das gerade alles nochmal ab. Ähm wo du, also es wird eine Rechtsgrundlage etabliert, dass es einen automatisierten Informationsaustausch zwischen,
dor
dem deutschen Inlandsgeheimdienst, dem Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und ausländischen Geheimdiensten geben darf. Das heißt, wir haben hier diese diese automatisierte Ringtauschgeschichten werden jetzt auch nochmal in Gesetz gegossen.
Ähm die gemeinsame Überwachungsdatenbanken von Polizei und Geheimdienst, Antiterrordatei, deren Laufzeit werden verlängert.
Und insgesamt wird polizeiliche Überwachung ausgeweitet und verdeckte Ermittler durch die Bundespolizei autorisiert.
Viel Spaß damit. Es ist natürlich relativ äh kritisch gesehen. Es gibt eine lange Reihe an Kritik, die Reihe an Kritik ist äh länger als die Reihe an Maßnahmen,
Ähm,
Diese Aufhebung der Anonymität bei Simkarten ist laut eben laut einem Gutachten der EU-Kommission ohnehin wirkungslos, kostet aber natürlich ein Schweinegeld, macht riesen Ärger. Ähm.
Berufslos im Sinne von bringt nichts oder berufslos im Sinne von die EU sieht's anders.
Den Unterschied verstehe ich nicht.
Gab's da nur eine Feststellung, dass das so eine Maßnahme nichts bringt oder dass es äh gibt's wieder so eine EU.
Maßnahme denn bringen. Also ich frage mich ernsthaft, was das äh was das bringen soll, ne? Ähm.
Also nehmen wir mal an, nehmen wir mal an, ich hätte eine zweite SIM-Karte, die nicht auf meinen Namen registriert ist. Und ich würde diese nutzen.
Dann kann würde ich doch zu keinem Zeitpunkt ernsthaft davon ausgehen, dass ich durch diese SIM-Karte jetzt irgendwie anonym bin oder dass das jetzt die SIM-Karte ist, mit der ich bestimmte Kommunikation durchführe
zur zur Vorbereitung allerlei
ungemach und davon ausgehen wird, dass deshalb in irgendeiner Form sicherer wäre oder weniger Sicherheitsmaßnahmen bräuchte in der Kommunikation mit dieser Semkarte. Wenn die Geheimdienstlichen Auswertungen ja ohnehin,
auf Basis dessen, auf Basis der Telefonnummer stattfinden und nicht unbedingt auf Basis der Person
Und wenn du dir dann irgendwie diese Mobilfunkdaten backen anschaust, kannst du natürlich problemlos herausfinden, dass dieses
Diese anonyme SIM-Karte, die was weiß ich auf,
vom Speti oder die Frau vom Spättier registriert ist, ähm sich die ganze Zeit äh genauso bewegt wie mein anderes Telefon, ja. Und wenn ich den,
Also es ist unglaublich schwierig, so eine so eine SIM-Karte ernsthaft nicht nachvollziehbar anonym zu halten.
Na ja, die wollen ja auch nur, dass die Simkarte, die der Terrorist einmal zehn Minuten vor dem Anschlag äh benutzt äh zu,
Befehl danach äh benutzen kann, um gleich eine ladefähige Adresse für den äh explodierten Menschen zu haben.
Ja
Man macht halt mal irgendwas. Man macht halt vor allem alles mögliche, weil vielleicht viel hilft viel. Ähm und das ist schon auch eine gewisse Hilflosigkeit. Die hier zum Ausdruck komm.
Kosten aller Handkosten, dann ähm bei internationaler Zusammenarbeit der Geheimdienste gibt es keine Begrenzung, dass man sagt, das gilt nur mit Staaten, die rechtsstaatliche Verhältnisse äh bei sich gelten lassen,
Also es gibt keine Mindestanforderung an welchen an die Demokratie oder die rechtsstaatlichen Verhältnisse in den Staaten der Geheimdienste mit denen man kooperiert. Diese Verbunddatei ermöglicht eben den Ringtausch
ja? Das heißt, ein Geheimdienst Deutschland darf.
Sagen wir das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz darf bestimmte Daten in Deutschland nicht erheben. Lässt sich die denn einfach geben von einem Auslandsgeheimdienst, der,
in Deutschland erhoben konnte. Ja, das heißt.
Trennung der Geheimdienste ist im Prinzip aufgehoben und alle Geheimdienste werden jetzt eigentlich zu einem Geheimdienst mit mehreren Abteilungen.
Genau. Dann natürlich eine der
der wichtigen Sachen, die immer wieder unterschätzt wird, ist, dass wir in Deutschland ja nicht ohne Grund ein Trennungsgebot zwischen äh von Geheimdiensten und Polizei haben, das jetzt im gerade im Rahmen dieser Antiterror-Datei-Geschichten immer mehr aufgeweicht wird.
Heißt konkret was.
Ähm der Geheimdienst darf dich ohne Richterbeschluss überwachen,
darf die Erlangten Erkenntnisse aber nicht verwenden um,
dich anzuklagen. Das heißt, er darf deine Grundrechte verletzen, ohne dich darüber in Kenntnis zu setzen, aber die damit gewonnenen Informationen dürfen nicht zu einer Verurteilung herangeführt werden. Und die Polizei,
braucht äh richterliche,
Genehmigung, um dich überwachen zu können und kann dann diese auf rechtsstaatlichen Wege erlangten Informationen vor Gericht gegen dich verwenden.
Durch die Zusammenführung von allerlei Dateien, wo alle irgendwie reinschreiben können und Datenbanken hast du dann eben geheimdienstliche Informationen gemischt mit äh polizeilichen Strafverfolgungsinformationen. Dieser Regentausch bezieht sich ja erstmal. Ja, genau.
Okay, aber dieser Ringtausch bezieht sich ja erstmal nur auf die Geheimdienste, nicht auf die Polizei, also oder siehst du jetzt hier auch einen einen.
Der.
Für den Geheimdienst Überwachungsmaßnahmen auch an die Polizei weiterzuleiten, die diese dann auch nutz.
Das machen die ja ohnehin. Also wenn ja doof.
Ja, die auch gerichtlich verwertet werden dürfen, meine ich.
Was man ja üblicherweise macht, also das Problem ist ja in Deutschland nicht so groß wie in den USA. Ähm wenn in den USA die Polizei eine ein Beweismittel auf nicht legalem Wege erlang.
Wird das ganze Prozess wird annulliert.
Dann geht dieses einfach nicht vor Gericht fertig, muss was anderes finden,
Was sie deshalb machen ist, dass das FBI im Prinzip das, was ich die NSA als Geheimdienst, dem FBI, als Bundespolizei sagt, pass auf, der und der macht das und das und wenn du den,
An dem und dem Tag, was weiß ich, in eine allgemeine Verkehrskontrolle ähm bringst, dann wird der das und das im Kofferraum haben und dann hast du deinen Anfangsverdacht, dann kannst du den unter die Lupe nehmen, ja,
äh ähm so läuft das da und auf ähnliche Weise wird das sicherlich auch in in Deutschland der Fall sein. Ähm,
Dann natürlich Datenschutz, das Ganze ist Personen äh bezogen, nicht irgendwie Einzelfallbezogen. Verdeckte Ermittler bei der Bundespolizei ähm,
Wird nicht wirksam auf sogenannte Schleuserkriminalität begrenzt, das heißt, sie können alles machen. Ähm.
Dann gibt's allgemeine Kritik daran, wie äh dass dass der Einsatz verdeckter bei Ermittler hier nicht ausreichend geregelt ist ähm.
Ja
Also das ist, ich meine, diese verdeckte Ermittlergeschichte ist nochmal was ganz anderes. Irgendwie ein Thema, mit dem ich mich nicht so viel auseinandersetze, weil es eben wenig netzpolitischen Bezug hat. Aber wir kennen ja diese ganzen Skandale auch äh aus Großbritannien war das doch glaube ich, ne? Dieser Typ, der da irgendwie mehrere Frauen geheiratet hat oder sowas.
Auf jeden Fall versprüht dieses,
Gesetz nicht unbedingt so den Gedanken, dass sich äh durch diese ganze NSA UA-Diskussionen in irgendeiner Form eine Erkenntnis durchgesetzt hätte, dass man doch vielleicht äh schon einen Schritt zu weit gegangen ist, sondern es hat sich eher die Erkenntnis durchgesetzt
Oh war, wie war's, das war jetzt alles äh verboten, dann ähm müssen wir das jetzt einfach mal alles erlauben. Weil dann kann ja auch kein Untersuchungsausschuss mehr gestartet werden.
Dafür darfst du jetzt nicht verwechseln mit dem ähm BND-Gesetz.
Das reicht ja hier mit rein, also in dem Moment, wo wir Datenaustausch zwischen Geheimdiensten haben, die jetzt im Rahmen dieses Antiterror-Pakets erlaubt werden, auch das ist natürlich dann wiederum ein äh potentieller Lückenschluss, weil wir gehen jetzt nicht unbedingt davon aus, dass es halt noch nie stattgefunden hat.
Wichtig finde ich daran, also wenn man sich das alles mal so anschaut, ne, alle möglichen Maßnahmen werden ausgeweitet, alle möglichen Dateien zusammengegossen. Aber da steht nirgendwo was drin, dass man sich mal irgendwie darüber Gedanken macht
wie man den Terroristen, denn den Wind aus den Segeln nehmen könnte, ne,
Also gibt's da irgendwelche Präventionen, ja? Also gerade was jetzt irgendwie Jugendliche angeht,
Das Einzige, was man den Jugendlichen anbietet, ist äh sie ab vierzehn schon äh durch den Verfassungsschutz bewachen zu lassen, statt erst ab sechzehn
ja? Ähm wer ja ein Angebot gewesen zu sagen, komm, dann machen wir mal Sorgen wir mal dafür, dass die irgendwie eine Perspektive haben, dann gucken wir uns mal an, was das für,
Leute sind, die irgendwie in diese in diese Terrorgeschichten äh getrieben werden oder für die das attraktiv ist und wie man den,
diesen Mist ausreden kann.
Und welche Probleme man irgendwie in diesen für diese Bevölkerungsgruppen ähm irgendwie lösen könnte. Tja,
Da gibt's übrigens eine ähm eine interessante Folge von der Podcast Metro laut, der sich damit auseinandersetzt. Also was ist das eigentlich? Was ist das für eine diese Terrorkultur? Die verlinken wir da auch nochmal. Da gab's ein,
Experten, der sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat. Finde, finde ich aber jetzt gerade nicht. Muss ich mal gucken, werden wir irgendwie äh auch noch verlinken,
Ähm genau, dann.
Hatten wir ja schon über das äh BND-Gesetz gesprochen. Ähm den Gesetzesentwurf zu Ausland, Ausland, Fernmeldeaufklärung,
Der im Prinzip sagt, okay, jetzt äh,
BND mal bitte im Style von NSA großflächige Internetüberwachung und ähm,
Das war ja zu den Zeiten, die wir jetzt in den letzten Folgen darüber gesprochen haben, noch in Entwurfsphase. Da hat jetzt die,
Bundesregierung den Gesetzesentwurf herabgereicht, um in dem Entstehungsprozess dem dem Gesetzwerdungsprozess zuzuführen.
Und da gibt es ähm.
Natürlich ziemlich scharfe Kritik. Äh Klaus Landefeld, der ähm,
beim äh Eco, dem Verband der Internetwirtschaft,
tätig ist und wenn ich das nicht falsch in Erinnerung habe auch bei diesem D-Kicks äh lange Zeit beschäftigt war oder immer noch ist, äh sagt also auch irgendwie so, okay, krass, das ist hier echt ein Freifahrtschein für die Komplettüberwachung des Internets,
Äh ein eine einzige Wunschliste ähm eines Auslandsgeheimdienstes ähm.
Die Brodollie geworden ist.
Der einfach das machen möchte, was die, was die NSA macht, ne? Und äh da gibt's also ausführliche,
Kritik,
Wir haben jetzt im Prinzip das, worüber wir vor ein paar Jahren uns aufgeregt haben und aus dem Staunen nicht rausgekommen sind oder ein Aufschrei durch die Bevölkerung ging, das haben wir jetzt hier einfach mal,
Untergeschrieben und auch wieder ohne ohne jegliche Einschränkung. Viel Spaß auch damit.
Ja er meint natürlich, das hätte alles vorm Verfassungsgericht wohl keinen Bestand, ist ja immer so mühsam, ne? Das sind immer wieder alles erstmal vor dem Verfassungsgericht keinen Bestand haben muss, bis es wieder eingeschränkt wird und,
wenn's überhaupt eingeschränkt wird und dann höre ich sie alles schon wieder, ja schön, dass jetzt hier das Verfassungsgericht mal Klarheit geschaffen hat.
Läuft's. Täglich grüßt das Murmeltier.
Das grüßt auch äh im Rahmen der üblichen Auseinandersetzungen zwischen den Verlegern und dem Blockerwesen,
Buchnetzpolitik berichtete mehrfach und wiederholt und äh in der konkreten Saga Axel-Springer-Verlag gegen Aio, welches ist die Betriebsfirma des Produktes at Block Plus
gab's jetzt eine weitere Gerichtsentscheidung in diesem Fall diesen Zivilsenat des Oberlandesgerichtes in Köln,
Es gab bis dahin schon zwei, drei Entscheidungen, die alle im Wesentlichen pro EU ausgefallen sind. Jetzt äh ging's konkret auch um das Acceptible Ads Programm von
was ja quasi so das Kernfinanzierungsmodell ist, was so läuft, dass eben Eio,
Partner auf eine sogenannte Whitelist nimmt die dann, wenn sie äh
brechend gestaltete äh Werbung bereitstellen, diese auch bei Installationen des Werbeblockers anzeigen dürfen, so der User das nicht ausgeschaltet hat,
und wenn äh das Plugin halt diese Werbung auch tatsächlich bis zum User durchleitet und damit ja Umsatz erzeugt, dann,
wird at Block Plus beziehungsweise EU äh an diesem Umsatz beteiligt, sonst keine Aufnahme, diese Whitelist.
Ich wollte das, also du hast das jetzt sehr diplomatisch wiedergegeben, ne? Also die haben eine ordentliche Nutzerbasis mit äh mit einem Werbeblock verballert
und sagen sagen dann den Werbetreibenden ah schöne Werbung haben Sie da, es wäre doch schade, wenn die nicht angezeigt würde, zum Glück haben wir, da gibt's da was von iO. Ähm sie können uns hier eine Umsatzbeteiligung an ihrer Werbung geben, dann wird die wieder angezeigt. Also das ist schon irgendwie.
Ich wollte das jetzt unaufgeregt und sachlich schildern im Gloss. Wisst ihr doch.
Wir müssen immer ohne, ja. Ich wollte das nur nochmal so Schildernes ähm.
Ja ja, ich ich hätte jetzt hier auch noch Steigerungsformen gefunden. Ich wollte bloß erstmal nur ganz äh.
Okay, sorry. Du wolltest erstmal das Spiel im Feld langsam aufbauen. Genau. Okay, alles klar. Nein, klar.
Stabil über die Außen führen und so bis man dann äh mal durchsticht und schnell zum Abschluss komm.
Linker Stürmer mache ich.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt halt abgepfiffen worden, dass Schiedsrichter bei ist, kann ich mir von vorne anfangen. Nun ja, also äh,
Du mal mit deinen Einwürfen. Ähm das Gericht befand, dass,
zwar Blockade der Werbung als solche nicht Wettbewerbswidrig sei. Was schon mal eine ganz interessante Aussage ist, weil wir dem im Prinzip entnehmen können,
AdBlocker als solche haben durchaus Bestand, zumindest vor dem Oberlandesgericht Köln.
Aber diese Geldkeeper-Funktion, in die sich AdBlock Plus da halt selber äh reingebracht hat, beziehungsweise EU, die sei halt nicht okay, weil hier ist eben schon so klar gesehen wird, dass an dieser Stelle
eine Rolle ausgenutzt wird und dass man eben Druck ausüben kann, dadurch, dass man da eben Kontrolle über den Zugang zu Nutzern äh erhalten hat,
Ja, da rulockt natürlich der Axel-Springer-Verlag und sagt, jetzt ist ja alles anders. Äh EU spricht nur von irgendwie einem,
Was war ihre Formulierung jetzt äh für verstärkt runtergespielt? Wobei ich mir schon vorstellen kann, dass diese Entscheidung durchaus kleine Schockwellen äh,
ausliefern durfte in den Laden
Da es sich ja hier um die Kernfinanzierung handelt. Also das ist sozusagen das, wo eben wirklich die Kohle reinkommt
Das Ganze geht natürlich dann wieder weiter. Nächste Haltestelle ist offenbar der Bundesgerichtshof.
Sieht also ganz so aus, als ob dieser ganze Fall äh höchstrichterliche Entscheidungen nach sich ziehen wird und ich glaube dann erst am Ende äh wird man das Ganze auch bewerten können, wie die Gerichtsbarkeit das dann tatsächlich sieht, ne,
Ja
Vielleicht ganz sinnvoll, dass äh hier unten mit ihrem Blätterplus schon mal auch irgendwie auf andere Einnahme äh Methoden schielt,
Mal gucken, ob die Kohle noch so lange reicht, bis das dann auch tatsächlich am Start ist und irgendwie auch funktioniert.
Da mache würden sie aber eigentlich ja auch das Gleiche machen, ne? Aber okay, da haben wir über Fletter plus hatten wir gesprochen, als es bei der.
Das ist nicht das Gleiche, ist nicht das Gleiche.
Gestellt wurde. Wenn sie ja wieder eine, na ja, sie würden diesmal statt Einnahmequellen, dennoch sie nehmen.
Es wird halt keine Werbung angezeigt, aber es wird dann halt auf Wunsch auch äh einen Geldanteil generiert, so. Also das ist schon.
Und das ist schon.
Aber es ist, es heißt ja ich fänd's schön, ich fänd's schön, diese Werbung weg, diese Werbung wegzuhaben, wäre einfach wirklich ein Gewinn.
Dann gab es mal wieder eine eine Woche mit interessanten Neuigkeiten zum Thema der Verschlüsselung. Erstens war Martin Schallbruch im NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss.
Das ist.
Der war früher IT-Direktor im Bundesinnenministerium,
Und der sagte dort, es wäre wirklich toll, wenn man möglichst viel Kommunikation verschlüsseln würde, ja?
Eine strengere Kryptoregulierung, also irgendwie ein Verbot von Kryptografie, das heißt, der steht überhaupt nicht zur Debatte in der Welt, in der wir uns gerade befinden. Ähm sagte also ganz einfach, alles verschlüsseln, möglichst viele Daten, Kommunikationsverkehre, jede einzelne äh verschlüsselte Ebay ist ein Gewinn und,
Dafür stünden auch im Lichte der Snowdenenthüllung vernünftige Verfahrungen zur Verfügung, die auch sicher sind. Der hat also ein Plädoyer für die,
Verschlüsselung gehalten.
Gleichzeitig wurde dann bekannt gegeben, dass wir eine neue zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich bekommen werden,
Die Zitis ähm,
wo hunderte Spezialisten dort die raffinierten Codes der Anbieter und Hersteller knacken sollen, damit Polizei und Verfassungsschutz weiterhin mitlesen können, deren große Sorge ist jetzt irgendwie äh WhatsApp und solche,
solche Scherze, die jetzt da eben,
verschlüsselt sind und das möchte möchte das Innenministerium nicht und äh hat da große Sorge, dass Going, dass ein Going Dark ja stattfinden könnte,
Ähm wie Georg Maskolo in seinem äh Artikel bei der Süddeutschen schreibt und,
Das geht natürlich nicht, dass hier Verschlüsselung ähm.
Dieses die Sicherheit des Landes schwächt und da sehen wir genau das, was die Leitlinie, die Thomas De Maiziere ja schon vor, oh, ich weiß nicht, vor wie vielen Monaten das war, vorgegeben hat, Sicherheit durch Verschlüsselung und Sicherheit
trotz Verschlüsselung,
Und das ist äh das ist das, was ich jetzt hier ähm manifestiert. Gleichzeitig alles in innerhalb einer Woche, ja? Ähm,
ist die Volksverschlüsselung an den Staat gegangen. Das ist ein ähm.
Produktname.
Ein Produktname, also das,
Das Problem, was es irgendwie gibt, können bei der E-Mail-Verschlüsselung ist ja irgendwie das eben Verschlüsselungssoftware zusätzlich installiert werden muss,
und man sich eben PGP herunterladen muss. Ähm,
Und dieses installieren muss, um PGP verschlüsselte E-Mails äh senden und empfangen zu können,
ähm einfacher ist es mit mit dem S meinem Verfahren, was in im Prinzip durch die meiste Software unterstützt wird, also so wenn du jetzt irgendwie Outlook oder Apple Mail oder irgendwie solche Standard äh E-Mails, Software benutzt, Tunderbird oder so,
die unterstützt das Essmeimperfahrten,
Aber sie haben überhaupt keine angenehme Möglichkeit, diese S-Mam Zertifikate mal zu generieren und zu installieren. Also es ist wirklich ein jedes Mal ein großer Schmerz, sich so ein erstmal Zertifikat klarzumachen. Ähm,
und die Empfehlung im Prinzip, was diese Volksverschlüsselung darstellt, habe ich in ähnlicher Form vor mehreren Jahren da mal äh.
Gegeben, als ich ähm ein Gutachter war für das E-Government-Gesetz, wo es um D-Mail ging,
Wo ich also gesagt habe, hier ähm bringt doch mal den Key offener Smartcard unter, zum Beispiel auf eurem neuen Perso, das haben sie jetzt nicht gemacht, aber sie sind das Problem angegangen, die Installation von Verschlüsselungssoftware,
massiv zu vereinfachen, da sind sie auch nicht die einzigen, die das, die das versucht haben, gibt's noch andere Projekte ähm und dieses ist eben am
Fraunhofer-Institut für Sicherheit in der,
Informationstechnik glaube ich heißt es, Fraunhofer SIT in Darmstadt entwickelt worden und ähm hat jetzt auch so eine Kieinfrastruktur dahinter, die von der deutschen Telekom,
ähm unterhalten wird und da kann man dann eben sich ein ein erstmal im Zertifikat zu seinem,
Personalausweis holen. Ähm werden mal sehen, wohin das führt. Ich habe äh die Software ist nur für Windhows erhältlich und erst seit ein paar Tagen. Ich bin mir sicher, dass da ein paar Leute drauf schauen werden,
und dann kann man das mal in Zukunft beurteilen wie da die Sachen im Detail aussehen und wie die Qualität im Detail ist.
Aber äh diese Verschlüsselungssache es ist wirklich eine spannende,
Immer wieder ein interessantes Thema, wie man wie einerseits Leute nach vorne gehen und Verschlüsselungen schaffen, Verschlüsselung ausrollen, andererseits Leute, die Hände überm Kopf zusammenschlagen. Das ist ein ewiges,
hin und her.
Ja und dann nicht in wollten das.
Der Name Volksverschlüsselung ist natürlich sehr ungünstig gewählt.
Also es erinnert vor allem an diese Bild äh Dinger da, ne. Bild hat ja immer mal ihr nehmen dann irgendein Produkt und machen das so richtig Billo.
Dann folgst davor.
Und dann heißt es Volk, ja, irgendwie Volksbibel, Volkshemd, Volkswagen, also was auch immer was haben die sich da alles ausgedacht, ne.
Wir machen, ich mach bald mal Volkspodcast.
Volkspodcast, ja, da wirst du viele Hörer haben. Ganz schön bevor.
Ja das ganze Volk. Klare Zielgruppe, ne? Ja.
Ja, Volksverschlüsslung ist so ein bisschen ähm.
Volksverdummung.
Volksverschussologen, ja der Volk irgendwo dran zu nehmen ist auch echt einfach durch, ne? Das kann man sich irgendwie merken, wenn irgendwie von Volk redet, der hat jetzt der hattet nicht verstanden, ne.
Volksverschusselung.
Volksbrexit. Na ja, Brexit Witze kann man Tim heute.
Der mir jetzt schon langsam aus. Nämlich schon fast alle gemacht worden.
Ja, hast du, bist du sicher?
Ziemlich. Aber mal gucken, das Ding nimmt ja nimmt bestimmt noch ein Pfad an. Ich glaube, da werden wir noch ein bisschen Spaß mit haben.
Dann gab's eine ganz interessante äh Recherche bei Netzpolitik Ork,
Und zwar hat sind die auf eine Gruppe aufmerksam geworden, die Abmahnungen bei einer nicht,
Lizenzgemäßen Verwendung von Creative Comments lizenzierten Bildern verschicken.
Creative Comments hat ja gibt's ja in verschiedenen Ausprägungen das äh CC By, wo die einzige Lizenzbedingung ist, dass du den Namen des Urhebers nennst ähm dann.
CC bei jetzt muss ich jetzt die Lizenzen referieren. Ähm das, ah genau, in äh,
Meine Güte, Leads. Dann gibt es das, also dass man etwas nicht verändern darf, ne? Sitze bei ND Note Rivitives, das heißt, du darfst dieses Werk ähm,
weitergeben, du musst den Namen nennen, aber du darfst es nicht bearbeiten. Dann gibt es CCBI NC,
Das heißt, du darfst es weiter, du darfst es weitergeben, du darfst es nennen, du darfst es auch äh manipulieren, aber du darfst all das nicht kommerziell tun.
Da wird's schwierig.
Dann gibt es CC bei NCND, also nicht kommerziell und keine ähm Bearbeitung. Ich glaube, das ist das, wo unter Logbuchnetzwerke erscheint, oder?
Ja. Weiß gar nicht. Ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, welche ja ist, ne? Also nix hier ändern. Dürft ihr nicht unsere Sachen äh in einen anderen Zusammenhang stellen. Also.
Werde ich euch reich machen damit. Deswegen haben wir auch keine Frechheit.
Deswegen haben wir auch kein Previewsley wahrscheinlich, weil weil man es nicht bearbeiten darf,
Ähm dann gibt es CC bei NCSA, also du darfst den, du musst den Namen nennen, du darfst es verändern, du darfst es aber nicht,
kommerziell machen und du musst das unter den gleichen Bedingungen weitergeben. Das heißt das was du daraus machst oder das wo es wo du es verwendest muss auch,
Die gleiche Lizenz haben, was wir zum Beispiel bei CC Bayern nicht hast, hättest, ja?
Und dann gibt es äh im CCBI äh SA, das ähm heißt also diese Namensnemmungsbedingung muss auch wiederum auf deins äh.
So sehen die so sehen diese Creative Comments Lizenzen aus und im Prinzip ist das ja auch so eine Idee des.
Discopy Left, also eine mein infiziert das Werk mit dem mit dem freien Gedanken und die Weiterverwendung ist entweder es nur ermöglicht, wenn dieser freie Gedanke weitergeführt wird bei den meisten,
Und wenn du jetzt in CCB-Lizenziertes Bild ins Netz stellst, ähm,
dann hast du eben den Anspruch darauf, dass dieses Bild, wenn es irgendwo verwendet wird, mit deinem Namen auch gekennzeichnet ist.
So, das passiert natürlich öfters mal nicht, weil dann irgendjemand ähm da nicht dran denkt.
Nicht einfach macht.
Die Software macht's einem nicht einfach, aber da gibt's ja diesen Lizenzgenerator, aber wie dem auch sei,
Immer mal wieder findet eine Lizenzverletzung bei.
Creative Comments Bildern statt und da gibt's jetzt eine ähm eine Seite namens Bilderdiebstahl DE, wo man sich quasi melden kann.
Und sagt, ich ich lasse hier meine Bilder von euch registrieren und ihr schaut darauf, dass diese,
dass diese Bilder von euch überwacht werden und wenn jemand ähm,
Wenn eine Person abzumahnen ist, dann bekomme ich dafür vierzig Euro. Für das erste Bild und zehn Euro für jedes weitere.
Die die Betreiber dieser Seite, Bilder, Diebstahl jedoch gehen dann zu den Leuten, die sie abmahnen und,
Verlangen dann irgendwie sowas wie hier in diesem Fall für zwei Bilder. Äh sechzehnhundert Euro Schadensersatz plus sechshundert Euro Anwaltsgebühren, das heißt die streichen einfach zwei zwei ein,
Zweitausendzweihundert Euro und speisen ihre,
Hinweisgeber mit fünfzig Euro ab. Da hat also dann der Markus Reuter von Netzpolitik Org ein bisschen recherchiert, wer was das denn so für eine für ein Unternehmen ist, was diese Seite betreibt und ist da auf einen sehr interessantes Geflecht,
Briefkastenfirmen äh gestoßen,
die ihre genaue Rechtsform noch nicht einmal äh erklären können. Ähm die außerdem in allerlei anderen Abmahngeschichten mit drin sind und mit irgendwelchen Fotografen,
zusammenarbeiten, die anscheinend ähm,
häufig gesuchte Motive fotografieren und quasi optimieren, dass sie dann auch schnell gefunden werden, um dann eben die Leute abzumahnen, weil wie wir wissen, die Abmahnung eigentlich das lukrativere Modell ist,
wenn du ein Werk heutzutage bereitstellst.
Wie gesagt, da gibt's dann große Flowcharts, mit wer kennt wen und mit welchem Unternehmen stecken die alles unter einer Decke? Ein sehr interessanter äh ein sehr interessanter Recherche, die da durchaus mal zu lesen ist. Aber,
Auch Einschätzungen hier in dem Artikel äh von,
mehreren ähm Abmahnern, Entschuldigung, von mehreren Anwälten, die ähm einmal in diesem, diese, die sich in diesem CC-Umfeld,
sehr gut auskennen, das auch mitgeprägt haben. Ähm Till Jäger und Volker Trip, die sagen, ja, das, was die da machen, das darf man.
Das ist nicht illegal dieses Geschäftsmodell, aber natürlich magst du maximal daneben, was da stattfindet. Also hier eine Leseempfehlung.
Dann haben wir im letzten Jahr, glaube ich, nur so am Rande erwähnt, dass die EU,
Was hat die EU jemals für uns getan? Tim? Äh freie Software verlässlicher und sicherer machen will und dafür im Moment erstmal eine Million,
Euro in den in den Ring wirft und man kann ähm nun abstimmen, welche Software da,
äh man man gerne äh mit einem EU finanzierten Outit versehen möchte. Das dazu kann ich nur ermutigen, da mal abzustimmen, während Julia Reder, die ja auch bei uns schon zu Gast war,
sagt derartige Pilotprojekte sind eine Möglichkeit für das Parlament neue Posten für den EU-Haushalt vorzuschlagen und sie möchte gerne,
dafür sorgen, dass dieses Pilotprojekt mit der.
Förderung der Sicherheit von Freier und Open Source Software Erfolg hat und dann dafür sorgen, dass es eine vorbereitende Maßnahme wird,
und mit einer Dauer von mehreren Jahren weitergeführt wird und dann irgendwann ständig in den EU-Haushalt landet. Ja, also im Moment ist es ein Pilotprojekt, dann kann es eine,
Treffertory Action, eine vorbereitende Maßnahme werden und dann könnte gibt es irgendwann nach mehreren Jahren eben die Chance, dass man sagt, das ist jetzt ein ständiger Haushaltsposten,
Bei der EU. Da möchte sie gerne ähm da möchte sie gerne drauf hinwirken und wer ähm
möchte, kann also jetzt dort diesen kurzen U Service mitmachen, wo ihr weiß nicht, zwanzig, fünfundzwanzig Softwareprojekte zur Auswahl stehen, dann kann man irgendwie begründen, was man da hat und äh oder
Vielleicht sind's auch nur fünfzehn, wo man eben sagen kann, okay, wir möchten gerne, dass dass dieses hier auditiert wird.
Sevensip Activity.
Ja, also man sieht das.
Art Sportschatz, ZDP Servert, Opalästic Serge, weil sie da, also im Prinzip die großen, dicken, fetten Teile, die so die Basis sind für vieles andere äh stehen hier zur Auswahl.
Nur bei der Ball sind, die ich noch nie gesehen habe.
Man kann auch äh alle anklicken und äh Potlawisher eintragen.
Na ja. Also bitter nötig.
Ach so ein Outlet würde ich auch gerne noch mitnehmen
nicht so einfach da Leute motiviert zu bekommen, die mal soeben sich äh die Security anschauen, ja? Also äh schon schwer genug überhaupt Leute zu finden, die überhaupt programmieren, Open Source Bereich, aber so Security und so, die winken halt alle nur ab und äh fragen nach Funding, die
Branche ist gut ausgelastet.
Also da kann man mal klicken und dann finde ich es auch ganz interessant, auch äh einer der unserer schönen Maßnahmen, die wir schon links haben,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die macht jetzt der Wirtschaftssorgen, da gibt es eine hm Pressemitteilung des Eco, die mich heute Morgen erreichte, äh wo Oliver Sühme
der Vorstand zu Politik und Recht sagt. So wie diese Vorratsdatensprechung im Moment implementiert ist,
Vor allem mit den Sicherheitsanforderungen, die für die Datenaufbewahrung hier bestehen.
Steuert das Ganze auf ein Fiasko zu. Die Bundesagentur für Elektrikgaskommunikation,
Post und Eisenbahn, also die Bundesnetzagentur hat den Entwurf eines Kataloges vorgelegt, in dem die technischen Vorkehrungen und sonstigen Maßnahmen bei der Aufbewahrung der Vorratsdaten,
ausgeführt werden. Und die sind relativ ausführlich,
Das wird kleine und mittlere Unternehmen schlichtweg überfordern.
Deshalb fordert der Eco, dass die kleinen, mittelständischen Unternehmen einen finanziellen Ausgleich für die Implementierung und die laufenden Kosten,
bekommen sollen. Und dass der Gesetzgeber generell praktikable und Europarechtskonforme Regeln schaffen muss.
Und da sieht der Eco im Moment äh sehr viel Nachholbedarf. Spätestens am ersten Juli zwanzig siebzehn, also in ziemlich genau einem Jahr sollen nämlich alle Provider damit anfangen, diese Daten zu sammeln und im Moment sieht,
der Eco nicht, dass sie dazu in der Lage wären.
Fragt man sich, warum da nur der Eco sich aufregt.
Also gut, dass sie, dass sie das tun, ja äh wo sind wir? Ja, logisch.
Na, das sind die Kleinen. Ja, logisch. Also deswegen regen sie sich auf.
Weil's die Großen ist äh schlecken das locker weg. Vielleicht. Leiden auf jeden Fall nicht in dem selben Maße und freuen sich, dass die anderen mehr leiden, ja. Ich hab's verstanden.
Tja und dann bleibt eigentlich nur noch.
Die Termine dieses Mal ganz im Zeichen des zwölften Juli. An diesem wird Berlin nämlich beehrt, wer denn niemand Geringeres als Günther
Öttinger wird
als Stargast auf der Bühne sein beim Bundesverband der Industrie, bei einer Veranstaltung unter dem Titel digitaler Binnenmarkt, starke
Industrie von zehn bis sechzehn Uhr dreißig in Berlin im Haus der deutschen Wirtschaft.
Eintritt frei.
Weiß ich gar nicht,
der sich da jetzt irgendwas gekauft habe. Ich glaube, ist kostenlos, ja?
Ach so, ähm, ich dachte man kriegt vielleicht Geld dafür oder so.
Nee, Serucan, Oettinger in äh Inserie, Inseriality, er baut the Cyber. Ja? Und,
Wer danach schnell fahren kann, schafft's dann noch äh zur Kryptoparty in den CC,
essen. Da äh geht es dieses Mal um das äh sichere Telefon, also wie schütze ich meine persönlichen Daten auf dem Mobiltelefon?
Auch am zwölften Juli zwanzig sechzehn ab neunzehn Uhr in der Sibillerstraße neun in Essen Süd,
Übrigens war ich äh war ich äh war ich Bäcker gewesen, ne? War ich beim Bäcker und dann hatten die ein neues Brot da. Das Brot hieß Essener Brot. Und dann habe ich gesagt,
Gib mir mal so ein Essener Brot. Und dann sagt der, ah, sie meinen.
Ich habe mich nicht mehr eingekriegt. Da war überhaupt gar keine Astro und Tigü.
Szene.
Soweit ist das jetzt in Berlin.
In Berlin ist das im Pott.
Nix in Import, da hätten die mir eine Lasche gegeben.
Damit werden wir am Ende dieser fröhlich, der dieser wieder erneut sehr.
Unterhaltsam.
Unterhaltsam, erbaulichen Sendung. Ich werde jetzt mich auch mal langsam beklagen und sagen, das ist einfach auch schlecht fürs Geschäft wie, also natürlich uns.
Hallo, ich will hier irgendwann will ich nichts anderes machen als diese Podcast und den Rest der Zeit Porsche fahren und so wird das nicht. Das hört sich doch keiner mehr freiwillig an, was wir hier machen.
Ja, das ist ein neues, neues, neues Feld, ne, sich die Pression Entertainment.
Na das können aber andere noch besser als wir. Ja, die kriegen das dramatischer hin. Sowas, weißt du, Entertainment braucht ja auch mal eine eine dramatische Wendung. Und hier gibt's ja nur.
Nur wir könnten einfach aktiver den Untergang vorhersagen.
Auch keine dramatische Wendung, der kommt halt also Entertainment, da braucht man auch mal eine Überraschung. Da braucht man mal eine.
Da hätte ich jetzt nicht mit gerechnet.
Gestalten, die irgendwie auf dem Pferd äh über den Hügel äh geritten kommen und die Freiheit verkehren.
Ja oder irgendwie mal sowas so, huch! Wow! Dramatische Wendung, irgendwas, wo man sagt, okay, krass, jetzt ändert sich etwas.
Aber wer hat noch irgendwie doch zumindest schon mal eine fast abgeschaffte Störaft?
Ja, ist aber auch ein paar Staffeln her, ne.
So, na ja. Ist es halt.
Ja, vielleicht müssen wir irgendwie umsatteln. Lokbuch Brexit.
Gibt's dramatische Wendungen.
Ja oder uns einfach generell mit dem Boulevard äh zuwenden.
Was gäb's da im Moment? Was hat das Boulevard zu bieten? Auch nichts, ne.
Personen und redet halt über Personen, weißt du auch, wie es ist.
Personen interessier mich nicht, da musst du dir jemand ander.
Ja tut ihr auch. Also bleiben wir bei den.
Wir bleiben in der Sackgasse. Sackgasse, Netzpolit.
So sieht's aus. Kurze Sendung heute.
Karrierekiller. Ähm Sendung heute. Zum Glück, ja wenigstens ist es schmerzlos. Äh äh wenigstens ist es kurz. Kurz und schmerzhaft.
Wir bedanken uns noch ein bisschen bei Peter. Wir bedanken uns bei.
Jochen bei Tore bei Thomas, bei Markus und bei Nora für äh die Unterstützung auch in dunklen Zeiten,
und ob ich schon wanderte im finsteren Tal, so fürchte ich kein Unglück, denn ihr seid bei mir.
Nee, das geht doch irgendwie weiter. Euer äh euer Hab und Gut tröstet mich oder sowas. Wie wie geht das Pime dreiundzwanzig, muss man noch könnten,
Als Heckert, da kannst du ja wohl wenigstens den Psalm dreiundzwanzig, den kann man sich ja wohl immer das, so viel kann man äh um ob ich schon wanderte, im Finster ein Unglück so viel.
Meine,
ist wirklich sehr eingesch.
Nächstes Mal machen wir das prinzipiell das bin ich irgendwie ein bisschen.
Okay, aber wenigstens ein Sendungsziel. Schön. Ciao, ciao.
Tschüss.